what i say to researchers is i trust
your intuition
in other words i believe that you are
right that now is the right time
to go try this
[Music]
david tennant house it is such an honor
to have you on 20 minute leaders thank
you for your time
thank you michael good to be here you
know i have your back from written down
next to me and i'm just overwhelmed
uh by attempting to start reading but
i'll give a brief intro and
and i'd love to then dive into your
experiences and so you know corporate
vice president
at you know the incredible companies
intel amazon microsoft
with the ceo of a9.com subsidiary of
amazon
and darpa's chief scientist faculty
member at mit partnered new venture
partners
vmware's chief research officer lp jay
ventures
david i cannot i only have 20 minutes i
have to get as much
knowledge out of you as i can did i get
that right first of all
was that okay do you think you got that
about right wonderful okay
david first of all what does it mean to
be the chief research officer
of an incredible company like vmware
which its foundation is based on
research
well the first thing is to be amazed
that people pay you to do this kind of
thing
and uh i you know i think it's it it is
actually like just a phenomenal
privilege uh
you've got these uh really smart people
and
uh you know a certain amount of it is
just about
uh helping them find their way helping
them connect with business opportunities
help them connect with new research
opportunities
um and uh you know really helping
kind of them get to the bottom of how to
maybe do more
with their great ideas wow okay so you
know running
chief research officer it sounds like
this it's not it doesn't only entail you
know being the head scientist in the
room and choosing the path
but it's also about culture it's about
how do you drive innovation and
creativity within a group
so how do you drive innovation and
creativity in a world
where vmware is such a significant
player in distributed systems and and
the work that you know i get to do on a
day-by-day basis
well the first thing to realize is you
know people always talk about r d i'm
just the
r right the d is the really big part of
r
d right so you know a certain amount of
this is still about working with
individuals
uh and as i said helping them uh
kind of take their great ideas so it's
really i think you hit a stage in your
career where it's more
less about driving your own ideas and
much more
about uh sort of embracing other
people's ideas
and really kind of helping them drive
them forward and then sometimes
standing back and synthesizing them and
say gee you know if we combine these
ideas
these ideas maybe we can work on
something bigger
that this is the challenge i think in
general in a research organization right
is that left to its own devices you'll
end up with
many more projects than you have people
wow and how many researchers are there
at vmware as we're speaking now
um so you know a certain amount there is
it depends how you count so first off
you can't really say
researchers at vmware because i'd say
there are probably many people in the
company that are actually conducting
research don't even know it
right but in terms of our our sort of
corporate
research it's actually a very small
group so think on the order of about 30
full-time researchers
we augment them we have post-docs we
have interns so
when you said right now we have an
enormous number of interns working with
those
folks so here in the summertime we're in
the peak of the intern season we have
interns from all over the world
uh this year they're virtual all right
i'm sure it's a it's a quite quite an
interesting experience helping them
guide the guiding them through this what
is meant to be a very monumental
experience in their career
yeah and then and so we augment uh
the key is getting amplification so we
also actually have a substantial number
of what we call affiliated
who are faculty members that are working
a day a week
uh roughly with vmware wow and some of
these folks you know have worked with us
in the past
uh you know so for example we have
people that came did a postdoc
with us now they're a faculty member
they continue to work with us
they send us interns so we you know
we're not just working with them we're
working with their team
uh and uh it's sort of so this is these
are ways that you amplify a research
organization
right by you know adding in these these
extra that's
that's wonderful you know my
relationship actually with vmware it's
it's funny
you know diane greene actually helped
sponsor
a hackathon that i ran when i was 18 in
silicon valley
for young young teens 18 and under
hacking generation why
my one of my latest computer science
professors is mendel rosenblum
and her husband and so now we're now
we're speaking so i'm getting to know
more and more of the vmware family which
is wonderful
but david i want to take you back in
time and i want to now to
to have a very selfish ask and i want to
talk about you know young entrepreneurs
like myself and going through the
incredible experiences you've had
from ceo of a9.com
to a partner at new venture partners to
being a vp
at three magnificent corporations and
what major lessons can i take with me as
i'm just starting on my journey i'm just
a baby here right
24 i'm just now you know dabbing i
i'm so curious what should i keep in
mind
as i go through this journey and all of
my friends should keep in mind as well
well you know i i think there's a whole
bunch of things people will always say
you know do the things you're passionate
about and they're right
i mean i think it's really important to
do that i think it's important by the
way
to about every five years stop and uh
consider right is it time to make a
change
um i think it's important to know
yourself so there are people by the way
who are passionate about one topic for
decades become the world's expert
in that topic and they just you know
keep going deeper
and and right and there's their skill
set
is in that depth and mastering that
intricacy in fact
you know when i was in intel we would
have it was almost scary because we had
what we call the fellows uh who were the
experts in any given technical area what
was scary was you had this immense
you know uh many billion dollar company
with you know really the hero of
lithography the hero of how to design
the next transistor the hero right
the hero of how to take the things from
the lab into production
uh but these people just you know we're
really good at that so that's knowing
yourself like maybe that's your
your thing right for me it's actually
been much more about
uh hybridizing right so in other words i
love sort of
going into new areas being a vc and
you're you're getting that experience
now right what's really neat is
each company you go it's likely that
that company is doing hopefully they're
doing something new and different right
so you can start a new business
of course you've got to learn all about
that new vertical that they're in
and in fact all the places that they go
and that their customers are in so
i think knowing are you sort of one of
these people that's
going to hybridize across multiple
places and that's your strength i think
of that as being a portfolio person
and i really came into that so when i
moved to darpa i was then going from
being a sort of researcher at mit
with certain you know i i won't say
narrow because i was working across what
i thought was a broad range of projects
but now i have a big portfolio right um
so as a vc it's more of a portfolio
and you know or you can be the
individual expert
both are great but i think it's
important to know and there are a few
people
not very many that can move between one
and the other right
right so i know that's good too but you
need to know which which category you're
in
a hundred percent and i think one of the
interesting challenges is that you know
at my age when
i'm just getting exposed to things you
know my my back story is that you know i
grew up in a very
tech savvy household my father's been in
tech for many many years
and i it took me a long time to get into
engineering
and one of the things that he said that
really convinced me was michael
you can't you can't assume your position
in the world before you
experience the different things so go
and learn engineering go become
good at artificial intelligence and then
decide what you want to spend the next
30 years on
but you can't make a responsible
decision without actually trying
and giving yourself a fair shot but
david i wanna now you know take you back
and think
what were some of the challenges as a
researcher early on in your career
that perhaps now are easier for you and
if you were to go back to you know young
david and your various different
positions you would what what insights
would you give yourself
to make the process a little bit easier
or or you know more more fulfilling
well i i think that you know there's a
couple different things there
i'd say is that uh you know i learned
from kind of one of my mentors
uh george falmar had uh
a sort of list of standard questions
that he would ask and unfortunately like
i didn't learn this list you know i
so you think i i started in canada i did
my graduate work in england
then i was at mit then then only after
that did i actually pick up on this list
it would have been good to know and
start but you know what are you trying
to do so again if you're
if you're in is a little different from
science because you know scientists are
trying to sort of
ask a question almost of nature uh
engineers we're trying to change the
world right we
are trying to you know kind of uh change
something
so what are you trying to do say it in
really simple words
you know get it down to you know google
they try to say it in five words
right but the important thing george
said was you know you know be able to
say it without a bunch of jargon
uh and then he had this quite a neat
question which is
uh uh so uh you know
how do people do it today now that was
kind of interesting because
curious think you're trying to do
anything new that nobody's done before
and you're gonna have this whole new
capability and what he's saying is look
if this is really important
people have worked out some way to do it
you know they may be doing it manually
they may be doing it through a crazy way
but there's somebody out there that has
figured out some way to do it
uh and you need to understand what that
is that so you're
replacing this place in some so that's
like you know really
you know kind of interesting uh then you
know what's your new idea
really right how's your new approach
how's it different
and what are the three heart problems
what are the what i now
call when i talk to junior researchers
the three what are the three rocks you
need to move
right in order to make this real and and
by the way
don't even try to move all three of
those because maybe this is again a
lesson
maybe if you move one of those rocks
somebody else or something else will
move one or two of them
in parallel so but at least know what
they are because you don't want to get
to the end and find that you got stuck
you know because it's something that you
should have anticipated
so now having sort of you know learned
about your you know he's you know i've
heard your story about your
your great brilliant new idea and your
new approach
you know so nobody's really followed
this approach before you think
and then his question was why didn't it
work last time
now unfortunately the way he asked this
question tended to be very discouraging
but i've learned to try to be
softer in asking it because what he's
really saying is look
it's probably the case that somebody
tried something like this before
don't get you can kind of get
discouraged
or you know and say gee damn i thought
this was a whole new idea
i only want to work on whole new ideas
i'm going to have to go find something
else
what you know what he was really saying
was
somebody's probably worked on a
variation of this
understand find it and understand why it
didn't work before
right and what i say to researchers is i
trust your intuition
in other words i believe that you are
right that now is the right time
to go try this even if other people
tried it five years ago
and others tried it 10 years ago and
others tried it 15 years ago
but what we need to figure out is why
your intuition is right
because probably what you're saying is
either the problem has changed
you know and actually we're going to
apply that idea from before
but to a different problem or somebody
moved one of those other rocks
right while we weren't looking some
other invention
has made this more feasible today or
something's changed in the business
climate or the business ecosystem
but knowing why your intuition is likely
to be right and that's something that
you know i wasn't
as good at i think that i've always been
an intuitively driven researcher and
it's important to know that first off
because it can guide your work
but second off because it helps you
explain it to other people
david i think this is what i'm what i'm
inspired about here is this
this id this open-mindedness and
curiosity that drives research
that you know and this whole time we
haven't even mentioned a single industry
or a single problem that you enjoy
solving we're talking about the core of
research
and finding opportunities and
re-examining reevaluating previous
opportunities that
perhaps had those big rocks stationed
there and now you know two years later
something has changed
somebody moved a certain needle that all
of a sudden paved the way and
your role as a leader of a research team
is to be able to
sort of embrace that trust your people's
intuition
and help motivate them to look for these
new opportunities
that might not have been there before
and by the way when they go
try that new idea that idea that maybe
people tried before
in these new circumstances by the time
they're done
it will be a new idea in other words it
will have morphed and changed and
they'll have added new insights
it's not just a matter of oh all you
know we're just
our you know the rest of our lives are
just kind of recreating ideas that some
ancestors have um you know it's this
this notion that as you go
through it you're actually changing and
gaining more insight along the way and
it's when you look back that you say
oh this is what was really important
right you know
anyway you keep going with your
questions because no no i haven't i have
i have one that you know
you probably don't get that often but
i'm still very curious
are you are are there any regrets that
you have on
things that you didn't do in your career
because with such an impressive career i
think it's very easy to go and say he's
done it all
and he's completely satisfied and
fulfilled and doing everything you
wanted to do but are there certain
you know positions that you wish that
looking back you might have wanted to
take a stab at
or different entrepreneurial endeavors
you might have wanted to do
no i don't think in terms of you know if
this is a mindset so
i just very i don't have regrets right
uh in that sense uh would it have been
nice to have had
you know a uh a unicorn when i was a vc
uh sure of course that would have been
great right
no but i think that i'm asking this
because you know my generation is all
about
fomo and it's all about you know fear of
missing out on different opportunities
and grappling with the different things
that the world
has and one of the things that i want to
take with me is how do i go about
my opportunities not constantly thinking
about what else is out there for me
i want to be in the moment love what i
do and concentrate on that
yeah you know it's it's interesting this
is is a discussion i often have with
people
so for example let's say i'm speaking to
a research candidate
uh and they've got offers from the
university and they've got offers from
us and they've got offers from another
company i'm sort of like
hey you know these this is wonderful
right this is what problems to have
is when you have these other
opportunities so it's
um i do get the the sort of
you know i can understand how people can
have the fear of missing out
uh and and what i'd urge them to to do
is just sort of look at this as what a
great high class problem to have that
you have all these different options
now go go get started on one right
when i was a researcher at mit i
remember being in a point where there
i was sort of spinning my wheels because
there were
three different major research
initiatives that i wanted to launch
i loved all of them you know
and what you know i eventually had to do
and i got some advice on this
was just start one and in fact
the advice was david you have to let one
of these things
you know kind of trick you into falling
in love with it
i love i love that i love that light
yourself
you know let yourself get sucked into
one of these so that you throw your
energy into it
and i did that and what you know because
i i was just sort of almost
holding myself at a distance from all
three
opportunities not diving in and
committing to anyone
what was interesting was you know what a
year later we had that first project
up and running and an opportunity came
by to sort of submit some proposals you
know so we
yeah you know we got the second one
going right
and a couple years later we got the
third one going and so
when i looked a few years later you know
i started them sequentially but in fact
we actually had you know i say weeks
with myself my graduate students you
know people work
as a team um you know so it didn't
matter
which order it mattered to just you know
uh let myself get drawn into one of
these enough
fall in love with them and not feel like
you and this is again a discussion i
often have with researchers you know and
say i'm not asking you to let go of that
other aspiration right
keep it i love it let's just get going
with this one first
and then we're going to get going with
the other one later i love that mindset
i love that mindset of leadership and i
love that mindset of
fall in love with what you do and and
you're not admit it's not that you're
foregoing different opportunities you're
you're choosing which ones to do now and
then and which ones to pursue later and
you don't know what later holds for you
as well
david 20 minutes go by way too fast and
i have to end with my favorite question
three words that best describe you
um i guess one is a you know a focus on
impact
okay focus on impact you know wanting to
change
the world this is you know in in a good
way of course it's a positive impact
i know that's an extra word hyphenated
um
i i think this sense of being a
hybridizer
or a tech polyglot i love that different
domains
uh and then the other is it's intuitive
um and i'm gonna you know kind of
confess that i'm not as data driven
as some people in other it's funny
because i champion
data driven research i'm constantly
trying to make our company a more data
driven company
but i will say that in a lot of things
in
research i think it does come down to
you know in
intuition i love that so much david
thank you for the inspiration thank you
for the time to do this
you have so much responsibility so many
people that that need you
and need your time so i really thank you
for being so generous with me
and and good luck with everything and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
great being with you you stay healthy
too and uh
just you know keep going with jay
ventures thank you very much take care
david
bye bye
you